it's time for another episode of
drinking whiskey welcome this fine
evening we are doing ha you guessed it
the last thing on the list a bourbon Oh
bourbon that is well it's defined by
many different things I'm glad you asked
generally the easiest way to tell them
apart is by region bourbon is America it
has to be just like Scotch has certain
rules bourbon has rules as well defined
by law so it has to be at least oh no I
think it has to be more than 51% by a
court distilled by corn so Scotch is
more like malted barley and but you get
bourbon which is still with corn yeah HM
new chart charred oak containers which
is what keeps a bourbon it's very
distinct more goldish tone Gold is not
the right word brownish yeah red bourbon
is very nice very nice I've tried all of
these and they are all very nice this is
the first time I actually cheated I was
supposed to record this video long ago
but there was just such immense pressure
from you guys to make another one of
these episodes when is the next episode
Felix I'm dying here
here we are finally with the Bourbon the
last of the series this will be my life
we're gonna start with a Cyrus Noble
which is the most expensive one guess
how much this one cost two hundred and
seventy two I think but it's a lot of
whiskey you got a lot of whiskey for
that price compared to the other ones
[Music]
I'm glad you're asked because that's a
mistake me and Jack made in the last
video so this is 80 proof which means
it's 45% alcohol there you go let's try
that as Cyprus Nobile
straight bourbon whiskey this is from
Kentucky fun fact about Kentucky whiskey
there are more barrels of whiskey than
are people living there don't know if
that's actually true I need to start
fact-checking better accepting things
rough yeah so 95% of all bourbon is
pretty producing Kentucky Kentucky bird
- Kentucky whiskey Burnham's the state
has more than 5.3 million barrels of
bourbon that are aging a number that
exceeds the state population I would
write cheese that sounds like a good we
need a move into Kentucky can you
imagine
that's incredible now I did realize it
for myself one hell of a glass but let's
give it a let's give it a try it's got
that very distinct bourbon nice spicy
flavor sniff on it it smells beautiful
I could smell this no you don't know no
this is exactly how you want bourbon it
tastes like I really enjoyed this
bourbon it's very nice the meme is so
dead it's a strong flavor it's not
unlike Scotch was that strong a lot of
scar chefs from flavor but they don't
but they're very usually a very smoky
this is that same strong flavor but
without the smoke smokiness it's more
spicy yeah Jefferson's reserved it says
very old on the bottle very Ojo Kentucky
straight bourbon but that's the thing
with bourbon
nothing is very old they America is not
a very old there's a lot of stories
about the original
[Music]
but generally people just agree on that
the scotch King the Scottish people came
and they're like hey we want to drink
something what do you got here to make
some some fine whiskey and they're like
hey we got corn I mean I'm just making
this up by the way this is another
Kentucky based Kentucky god bless see we
should go to Kentucky it's a very small
batch bourbon each longer than its
deployments for an extra slab of spicy
complexity very nice I guess the thing
with with drinks is that maybe I should
just drink it I actually think I like
that one more than hmm do you want to
smell it okay I think the Cypress isn't
better overall the flavor in your mouth
when you have their reserve it's
beautiful but I'm not sure if I like the
kick the spicy kick that it describes it
is significantly cheaper but it's also
very nice yeah I think that's it yeah
something 76 maybe none of the Bourbons
are very expensive I would say compared
to the Scotch the personal prices of the
Scotch is pretty outrageous 1964 that's
when they declared that bourbon was
bourbon by my state of law so bourbon is
pretty young they've been making it for
a longer time obviously but has bourbon
hasn't been bourbon for more than a
hundred years at least even though
they've been making bourbon for more
than 100 years garrison brothers
everybody this is a Texas straight
bourbon whiskey so it's not from
Kentucky hi this is the most cowboy
whiskey I've seen and they really try
and promote it that way I think they
have a bourbon cold Cowboys
that's the thing with the that I think I
really enjoy about whisky it sounds a
bit pretentious but it's more than just
a drink it's it's immersing yourself in
an experience you drink the Laphroaig
and you imagine yourself in Scotland
you drink some bourbon from Texas and
you feel like a cowboy you know what I
mean yeah
the flavors are all so different I don't
know how to describe it
the spicy flavors man the spicy I keep
going and spicy but none of them really
feels fantastic to me they're all very
nice but so far it's not it's not like
some of the Irish whiskey that I tried
that are just like them oh my god this
is all I want to drink except they have
the COBOL single berry whiskey rye
distilled in Chicago this one tastes
crazy that's all I remember
yeah it's very different very very
different they all taste so different
from each other but this one tastes
particularly different it's so strange
some bourbon is so strange I don't even
know if this is bourbon this tastes less
I was just gonna say this one tastes not
as strong as the other ones but I guess
you would disagree but I do like it
obviously I drank quite a lot from it
but I don't I don't know next one I am
very excited about this is 100% straight
corn whiskey so it's not bourbon oh
that's the thing I forgot to tell about
this one cuz this is hey I just noticed
that there's a difference between
Kentucky Bourbon and Tennessee bourbon
I think the bottle that it couldn't find
was the Tennessee bourbon and they
really try to make themself their own
thing in Tennessee it seems like they're
like oh we're not bourbon we're we're
Tennessee whiskey alright calm down
this one clearly feels like they took
moonshine and marketed it kind of they
got a freaking wizard I try this one
it's one of the cheaper ones it's
actually very nice it's actually really
good I can see since 100% corn it's a
lot brighter than the other ones it
looks so much like Irish whiskey this
feels like that kind of stuff you today
you drink with some ice maybe you don't
have to be like oh oh yeah way less
flavors than all of the others but it
still tastes real smooth I really like
it I don't know I just bought it because
I was like holy crap that bottle looks
insane maker's mark has been put on the
map recently becoming very popular in
the UK it's a Kentucky straight bourbon
whiskey handmade they put I don't know
what that in place I think when you get
to the really cheaper whiskeys typically
you wouldn't really enjoy it like the
rest but this is one of the cheaper ones
that I actually would really enjoyed
this did get a lot better
so much flavor so much spice you feel
like cowboy last but not least the Jack
Daniels Jack Daniels has set specific
flavor and it goes really well with
mixing if you want to make yourself a
highball it's very nice to do that
learning sparkling powder and some Jack
Daniels and you got yourself a highball
and it's it's a very nice drink I mean
doesn't dehydrate you like a lot of
other drinks do like we keep drinking
gin and tonics or keep drinking all
these fancy drinks you're not gonna feel
good the day after but you drink just
whiskey water you know you can't go
better the night Jack Daniels everybody
that whiskey that probably most of you
that are watching have tried its a
Tennessee whiskey and they make they go
out of their way to say oh no we're not
a bourbon we're a Tennessee whiskey see
that's what I was getting at before
apparently what they do is they drink
the whiskey through charcoal charcoal is
that possible that's what gives it its
really distinct flavor and it is so it
is a nice flavor I understand why it's
so popular I think because it has a
brief black label they did a really good
job market again we study actually this
economy how they market it and black
really put them on the market that's a
manly you know product you see people
all the time like yeah we could Jack
that man right it's my last it's been
fun guys it's been fun all the memories
it's been so many memories so many
wonderful times I want to thank you guys
for this opportunity I want to thank the
all the community of whiskey drinkers
and most of all I want to thank myself
here's to me
[Music]
that was it
that was all the whiskey might do
another video if I got enough thumbs up
can we get this to trending a final wish
are you live for me you don't think I
can get trending challenge accepted
everybody um that was that good
goodbye everybody and remember keep
drinking safely water drink water